[Music]
you're living the dreams DP yeah
strong guys sorry I'm late I was
rounding up all the gluten in the world
and launching in space where it can't
not hurt us ever again kiss me like you
miss me read what in the ass
my name's cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid mover died
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be he needs you
a lot smarter than I look
I let cable kill this kid but I can't do
this alone we're gonna form a super
duper group that's what we're gonna do
before we're thinking gender-neutral we
will be known as x-force you're
absolutely right now cue the music
don't call it a comeback
tell me they got that in slow motion you
and the right thing is messy but if you
want to fight for what's right sometimes
you fight dirty that is why the man bun
is just a millennial mullet
oh god I wish I finished college it
lives up to the hype
plus plus they probably won't even make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it
[Music]
my pants actually that may have been me
oh you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care stronk eyes beautiful
girlfriend
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again
kiss me like you missed me red what in
the [ __ ] sickle is this
my name's cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid mover died
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be a made you a lot smarter
than I look
I let cable kill this kid but I can't do
this alone can you speak up
it's hard to hear you with that pity
dick in your mouth we're gonna form a
super duper [ __ ] group meet him topic
morally flexible and young enough to
carry their own franchise for 10 to 12
years x-force you're absolutely right
now let's go get our [ __ ] on don't call
it a comeback
tell me they got that in slow motion
you're the right thing is messy you want
to fight for what's right sometimes you
have to fight dirty
that is why Sisterhood of the Traveling
Pants is pure pornography oh god I wish
I finished college it lives up to the
hype
plus plus dark it they probably won't
even make it three yeah why would they
stop it - you killed it
you